[Music]
uh
your entire career i want to talk about
how you how you got to army the dead and
that sort of
it brings me back but i remember the
first
pay-per-view i ever bought was
wrestlemania 21
in uh 2005. so i i've been
you know sort of following your career
over the years and to see you become
primarily known as an actor to see you
become
this this success in both you know small
quiet dramas big franchises has been
has been wild i'm wondering if you you
reflect on that ever if the trajectory
of your career
surprises you or if this is this was the
goal
definitely wasn't the goal and it's uh
you know i guess if you say you know sit
back and reflect and i think about it
and i think wow
it's crazy but man usually i'm just so
wrapped up in the moment and like
day to day and so i don't put uh i i
don't put a whole lot a lot of stock
into
it you know i live a pretty simple life
and i think
you know my goals are i think my goals
are
i don't know my goals are very grounded
you know what i want to achieve in
acting what i want to achieve in film
and entertainment
is all it's all very grounded and i do
it for very personal reasons
so it's not so i don't get wrapped up
into
you know how big it is how large it is
or how people might perceive it as being
like this great big career because my
life is so simple
my life is so grounded so i don't really
i don't really reflect in that manner
but
but yeah like when you say yeah reflect
on think about think about you
even like when i think about like i
remember wrestlemania 21
like leading up to it so vividly that
it's i mean it's really
it makes me emotional thinking about it
i i barely remember the match
i don't remember the match much at all i
remember breaking down after the match
but i can hardly i can hardly you know
recall the match it's a weird thing it's
just like
it's kind of gone i was also i struggled
physically
to even going into that match but i was
just i was so nervous and i
i didn't sleep i was so wrapped up in
that moment because it was some place
that i
never thought that i would get and so i
remember like
just being emotionally just i just broke
literally broke down i think i cried for
days like even now thinking about it is
making me emotional
it was something i never thought because
you know it was not long before that
where i was um you know i was
i was borrowing money from people i was
borrowing money people for me
people to put food on the table i was
borrowing money to
buy my kids clothes i was borrowing
money too you know for the simple
necessities in life i was living in a
a tiny little apartment at one point my
wife then
then we were driving around in a honda
del sol and i don't remember
if you remember the honda girl so they
were tiny little
two seaters and that's what we shared
and that was a luxury for us to even
have a car
so it's just uh yeah and then think
about it now
um it's weird and i have you know i'm
living a second life here
because i was successful as a
professional wrestler but then when i
left it i i lost
everything like i lost everything i went
broke and i had to rebuild my name i was
starting over with my name i was
starting over career
you know new career and at that time in
in
hollywood i mean most
people were they weren't they weren't
familiar with professional wrestling
and if they were they didn't care didn't
care how big i was in professor
wrestling it didn't matter to them they
didn't get it they didn't understand
how big professional wrestling was
across the world it was just some kind
of bad cliche to them
and so they didn't really understand it
they thought professional wrestlers were
just a bunch of oiled-up guys who beat
each other up in rings and they didn't
really know
you know the details and how much went
into professional wrestling and how
much people like really loved it and
were passionate about it and how
how passionate the performers were about
it because i always looked at
for me professional wrestling wasn't as
an art it was a performance it was a
theater of violence and that's the way i
looked at it and that's the way
you know that's the way i performed it
throughout my career so it was just uh
sorry i know i'm getting late i'm giving
you a really long answer
completely that makes my job so much
easier it's it's
for me to reflect like that the honest
answer is i just don't because i'm
i'm just so caught up in in the moment
and i'm always looking
to i always man i i just have this real
big fear of wasting my
life so i'm always looking for the next
step ahead the next move the next
thing that's going to get me to where i
want to be and to where i want to be
is going to change from now to two years
from now it's i wouldn't want to be
somewhere else and it's
like something that it's like a hunger
that i can never satisfy
so i don't know where that stems from
probably from desperation but
it's it's just it's always something
it's always a dream i'm chasing
constantly chasing i can't i can't catch
it i'm just constantly chasing
it's so interesting you mentioned you
know how you remember the lead up to a
match you remember
you remember the afterwards we don't
remember remember the match itself is
that something you find
happens uh with acting is it sort of
similar to the switch to performing in
front of a camera for until they say cut
or is that a completely different piece
i think uh no it's so different man it's
so different it's
this is why this is what's been the real
struggle for me with acting and which i
what i really love about it but also
find find so challenging is that
there's so much more room to be
self-conscious in acting
because it's such a detailed nuanced
thing that
it's a it's so you know can be so
intimate
whereas professional wrestling i was
always con i was always confident in my
physicality
so to go out in front of a crowd i was
always nervous i mean like i was dry
even before every match even up to my
very last wrestlemania
but when i got out there i was confident
with my physicality
but it was when you put a microphone in
my hand when i had
like to speak words to communicate was
when it was like a struggle for me
because i've always had
i've always had you know issues with
that
but i was always confident with being
physical
um but it's the intimate things that
just they they hit me at the core of
my self-consciousness so it's been a
struggle but it's also one of those
things where the more i do the more
comfortable i am
i feel like the better i become and i
feel like
it's that's the same like i always feel
like i can be better i know i can be
better i can do better and after every
job i want i want to work more i want to
do more i want to work
you know more actors better accomplished
actors better accomplished directors i'm
always
i want to work for the i feel like
that's how you become the best you work
with the best and you become the best it
was
same mindset i had in wrestling work
with the best learn from the best
pick their brains learn everything they
like be a sponge around them be a
student
it's the same with film i'm just i'm
ravenous for it man i'm ravenous to
learn about this business and i think
it's all because
at the end of the day like i really just
i love telling stories i love
inspiring people and so that's that's
what i want to do that's you know that's
the stuff that got me through when i was
a kid
you know tv and movies and cartoons and
stuff that maybe you know inspired me
and made me
want to get out of my you know my
neighborhood and get away from this
you know violent atmosphere and and go
out and see the world and
so it's each step of my career it's been
it's become
you know more and more and more and i
see the world completely different than
i did 20 30 years ago
with wrestling i feel like it's it's
such a immediate
response to your performance you know if
someone in the crowd or the crowd
doesn't like what you're doing
you know that immediately and i'm
wondering if that's something you missed
because
you know you film something like army of
the dead you rap and then you wait
months and then you talk about it then
it comes out i'm wondering if that's
something you miss
i miss it more than i can say it is a
drug
it is absolutely i understand why people
have a hard time letting go of that i
understand why professional athletes
have a hard time letting go of that
because it is absolutely an addictive
drug it's an adrenaline rush
like there is nothing there there is
nothing like that response of like a
wrestlemania crowd who's just
losing their minds and it's like the
weirdest thing to go in
in front of a hundred thousand people
live and every you know that everybody's
focused on you
it is such an intense feeling and it is
you know it's it really is a gamble i
think it's almost you know
being a gambling addict because you know
it's either going to be that super high
where you're just going to be
you know you just won a million dollar
pot or you're going to be that super low
where you just lost
everything and it's like it's so it's
that that risk that risk factor i think
people just thrive on it and i was
fortunate enough in my career that most
of my
most of my gambles were were victories
they were yeah i went to that million
dollar pot
but i had some stinkers too and they
said
but it was the stinkers that made me
want to be better it was even you know i
found out that i was a horrible actor
that made me want to be a better actor
so i think it's like kind of those
things that drive us but there's nothing
nothing like um a live crowd man i think
every performer will
will tell you the same thing there's
nothing and it's very easy to get hooked
on that and it's
hard to walk away but i miss it i miss
it daily
like and i know that i if i wanted to go
back i know i could
i know they take me back i know i could
go and perform i wouldn't be able to
compete at the same level but i know
they would take me back and i know i
would have something to offer
i just won't do it i won't i just my
career ended it ended so perfectly i
just wouldn't dare tarnish that
but i i miss it i miss it all the time i
hear my music and i'm losing my mind i'm
thinking god i missed that
like my entire community just shuts me
off man pushed me and i was gonna say
it's one of uh it's one of the highest
entrance musics of all time it's just
amazing amazing
the sort of complete opposite spectrum
of that i feel like something that
really
you mentioned you know when you started
going to hollywood uh there's this idea
of a wrestler turned actor
and i think something that really
flipped that on its head especially was
your appearance in blade runner
was 2049. a it was such a different side
of you and it was such a
it was using your physicality for a
tender
performance which i think really just it
will people up to to what you can do and
i'm wondering
what you remember from filming that
scene and what you remember from sort of
the aftermath of it
so even though getting that role was a
whole process
uh where denise did not originally want
me for that role
and so anyway i finally won him over
through a pretty you know a series of uh
you know pictures and screen tests
and makeup tests but i eventually won
him over but i won him over playing
sapper
a particular way when i did my screen
test and my audition test
i played i played sapper very ominous he
was very
you know he was intimidating and so i
was hired
you know upon those screen tests and so
i thought that's what denny liked
so when i showed up to film um and i
started performing supper like that like
though you know i did my screen test
and he was no no no no no
that's that's all wrong that's all wrong
and then he took me aside he said
he said i you know supper he's not um
zapper's not intimidating suffers not
menacing
cyber's sad you know if he this guy you
know he doesn't want to fight
he he just wants to live and so i so
right there on the spot i started
reprocessing
you know supper's whole mentality and
started performing him very differently
and every take you know denny was coming
in and he's saying
i need you to walk with a little a
little more you know a little heavier
a little more weight on your shoulders a
little more you need to be a little bit
more broken down
uh everything you do with putting on my
glasses i need you to put your glasses
on a certain way like you've done it a
million times you do this
but they're very dainty and they should
look very dainty in your hands but i
want you to put
so he just like directed me and i was
told like this is what i love this is
why i love working with
directors because without him directing
me that performance because he
saw it a different way than i did i
never would have i never would have
performed sapper that way and i never
would have gotten
the credit that i did but that role
changed my career because
people they looked at me differently
after guardians i had
definitely had the respect factor as an
actor but they didn't see me as a well
arranged actor
and after i did sapper like a lot of
people didn't even make the connection
that i was the same person but the
people
knew were surprised that i can not only
do this guy but i can also do this guy
and now my range is starting to expand
and now i'm starting to achieve what i
set out to do
and that was be a respected actor that
film opened tons of doors for me that
small part and that was what i was
concerned about
i like i didn't think anybody would even
recognize me in that film i was there it
was so
so fast and i was like they had me out
promoting like promoting the film was
like why did they have me out here i'm
like
barely in the film people aren't even
gonna know that i'm in the film
but man i got so much love for that
little part and it's something that i'm
like
super grateful like i don't overlook
that for one second even though it was a
small part
like i i just it did it just it just
made people look at me differently and i
got a different
level of respect as an actor for it for
that part and
also you know and then turn it it um got
me the part in dune which again i think
it was going to
have people look at me look at me
differently i was going to ask because
you know
you're reuniting with me and it's sort
of i'm wondering if
it's offering you a chance to do
something new in a different way is it
is this something is this another new
step new opportunity for you
oh for sure for sure not only like i
really we so we tracked
we tried we tracked that movie for for a
month because i wanted to be a part of
it so bad
and we never i never reached out because
i don't want to be that guy like i don't
want to
you know hey denny is their part and you
know i never
wanted to be that guy but he actually um
he called me
and he didn't didn't we didn't say
anything he didn't say anything about
you know there's this part he wanted
then she just straight out just asked me
if i would come and play this part
and i was so like taken aback i didn't
even know what to say
like except for obviously yes absolutely
yeah but
that just like that like moments like
that really
gauge uh how far i've come you know as
an actor because it's not
you know there's a lot of um
there's a lot of pride in it for me that
a director like
denny would just call in and offer me a
role in a film that i know is going to
be enormous because people have been
waiting for this for
years and years and years and people are
so passionate about the novels
so i knew it was gonna be huge and uh
for him to offer me such
you know integral part of this film it's
just i mean for me it was a personal
statement that uh you know you can i
mean i can't purchase that
type of emotion like that type of
feeling that sense of pride i can't
you know these are the few moments in
life where i get that where i feel
like my life has been you know my life
has been worse something i did something
with my life so my life means something
oh you can get me emotional again
um but but we talked to you i think a
few years ago
we were talking about infinity war
collider was talking about if anyone you
and you mentioned you didn't
read the script the entire script
because you didn't want to be spoiled
i'm wondering if something with
something like dune
you did the same thing or when you got
the script you're like okay i want to
see what the full picture is
yeah yeah i did you know i did that and
i yeah i did that with denny and i did
that in blade runner as well and i said
i don't want to read the script because
i i like to go and like especially stuff
i'm excited about
like i want to go and watch it as a fan
and um
but denny was very insistent that i read
the full script of blade runner because
he wanted to know how i fit into the
film
you know he wanted to know the whole
story how i fit into the film so i could
you know connect my emotions to the
whole story not just to these little
moments that we're creating
and so the same thing with dune i did i
read through the whole script but
i would prefer um to not read i would
like to i would prefer to the projects
that i'm in that i'm in a you know part
like that unless i'm the lead if i'm a
lead in a film i need to know everything
that's going on i need to know every
character
and what their arcs are but for a film
like this where i just serve a certain
purpose in a particular
moment i'd prefer not to read the entire
script because i i
i'm at the end of the day i'm a fan
first and i want to go and watch these
films as a as a fan
so uh but yeah so i'd say you know it's
just i don't know part of who i am i
guess
i'm always i always say fanboy first and
that's kind of led me
to end every other thing but yeah i like
to uh if i can
you know prevent myself from spoilers
i'd like to do that
i think that the excitement for dune is
kind of reaching like a fever pitch i
think you know when they announced it
was coming to streaming it was like
i think the closer we get to it people
just want to see what this movie is and
i'm wondering what
as a fanboy what was your reaction to
the script
um i was i was blown away i was blown
away i don't think um
it's weird because when i
when i read blade runner when i read
dune
it's hard for me to know what their
visions are
especially what denny's vision is
because he's just such
the worlds that he creates are just
they're so enormous like i could never
i don't think i could ever direct a film
like that i think my talent would be
lying and lying a very contained um
drama
like that's what i would like to do
that's what i aspire to do but
creating these even like james like
creating these universes these galaxies
they're just so
far over my head so i read it and i
thought it was beautiful
i was emotionally invested in it and the
script and the characters
but i don't think that my imagination
stretches that far to create
these worlds so it's it's going to be as
big a movie as
people are expecting it's going to be
the event that people are expecting
absolutely yeah absolutely amazing it's
very interesting that you mentioned
you know you didn't want to go to janae
and ask uh you know is there a role for
me because
you've made no secrets about wanting to
play bain this
story came out came out recently and
it's very interesting to me because i
i think i feel like the more we have
these established universes the more we
have
these stories of people going to the
studio on being like i want to play this
role
i'm just wondering sort of what what was
the
the moment for you where we're like i
i'm the person i should be playing was
it was
yeah there was something about you know
there's certain characters that i've uh
i don't know i've just kind of latched
on to over the past
10 20 years and bain was one of them and
not like not like
not like no discredit to like tom
hardy's version of bane
i love i loved his performance i love
that film but i just feel like uh you
know i'd love
i love a crack at it i think i could
bring an interesting twist to it and i
think i could do the character justin
justice uh not only um and performance
but also on physicality like i'd love
that role where i just had to
you know sit down and go back up to like
320 pounds
just to portray this character like i
would like that i would happen
um but i just feel like i could do this
character justice and bring
you know really bring like a strong uh
performance to him as well and play bain
in a way
you know that's not only menacing and
ominous but also like freakishly
intelligent
you know and just terrifying in that
manner and also
like i i think that bane would be the
type of character
that's so menacing and so terrifying
um and so intelligent that he would
hardly ever raise his voice
you know i think he would almost be like
a like it missed
the character i played in bond mr hinks
was so terrifying
his demeanor hardly ever changed
actually he was very happy to be
beating the hell out of someone he was
he didn't you know he wasn't like super
early
because they were just so confident in
what he was doing and i think that's the
way
i think that's the way i perceive bain
to be as well because he's not only
he would be physically superior but he
would also be
mentally superior and i i just loved it
i loved the idea of that
the challenge of playing that character
because i like i like when you can play
a brute
who's not your you know your predictable
brute
he's a brute that he doesn't need to
raise his voice because anybody any big
muscular guy can play that guy who's
screaming and
and growling and you know but if you
play a guy who's
not only physically menacing but is
soft-spoking
soft-spoken and just as terrifying even
more terrifying
when he's speaking to you softly with a
smile on his face
then that is a villain that's a villain
i want to play you know so that's
that's kind of like the way i see pain
in that and i did i i
i don't make any pretense about it so i
had a chance to get him you know meeting
at wb and i walked in and i
they were talking to me about this and
that and i said hey let's talk about
let's talk about bain
[Laughter]
you know that happened to me one other
time in my career and i had a meeting at
universal
and they wanted to talk to me about fast
and furious and i said i'm i'm
not interested let's talk about marcus
phoenix you know
and so what's the connection to that
they should go
i think again i think they were a little
put off but you know it's like man you
you get a shot i don't mean to offend
anybody i'm not putting down anything
else i'm just saying
like this is way more interesting to me
i don't want to you know pretend like
i'm actually interested in something
i'm not when i when there's something
i'm actually really excited about that
you guys
you know you guys have under control
like would you consider me for that i
mean i don't think there's any harm in
that i'm not trying to
be step on anybody else tell anybody
else's toes or disrespect anybody else
i'm just saying like this is what i love
man i'm i'm seriously passionate about
this like i
do a good job for you guys on this so i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that and so but twice in my career that
happened
and twice in my career didn't pan out
not not yet not yet still if i had given
the
opportunity again i would just you know
i don't
see any harm in chasing your dreams or
being honest with someone
and saying man this is what i really am
passionate about i'd love you know if
you guys would consider me for this
i'd really you know i'd do this justice
you know i think when people are more
personally invested then it's just going
to be a better product
you know absolutely absolutely and that
sort of leads me to my to my next thing
about the the superhero character you do
have in the dude
which is drax and i know from what i've
heard you really like
worked your ass off to get this role it
was it was not just you know
there wasn't just offer to you you were
you're in contention with other actors
you were yeah
and i'm wondering you know at this point
it's your three movies in
but to look back on that audition
process how much did it mean to you to
get that validation they're like you
have the role and you earn and you earn
the role
um you know what's weird man is um
it uh that that role changed the
trajectory of my life man
it's always going to be special to me
now
i'm um four films in which i can
confirm more on the way
um i really wish that they would have
i really wish that they would have
invested more in drax you know
personally
because i think drax has more of a story
to tell and i think drax has got a
really
interesting back story which they
dropped the ball on
and that's you know dick no dig on
marvel you know they had their slate and
i know what they're focused on and they
just that's what they had slated out
but man i think they really missed the
ball on drax i mean he's got such a
great backstory
and that would you know as selfishly as
a performer that would have given me the
opportunity to show like different sides
of direction emotionally
uh and physically as well because if you
notice like drax
you know although he looks like a badass
you look at him drax looks terrifying
drax gets his ass kicked more than any
other marvel character
someone nickname for someone nicknamed
the destroyer he was very often getting
his ass kicked and that's you know the
whole destroyer thing they just threw
that out the window but you know there
was
you know shades of that you know that
they mentioned in the first film
but it's just i guess they you know
people fell so in love with the comedic
side of
if drax they just tapped into that and
then they tapped into it more and then
they just really dug a hole on it
but i think i think you know
you know we missed a huge boat on that
character and i don't think it'll ever
come back around but i
i'm really just looking forward to kind
of finishing out this uh this whole
journey with
the cash and everything now that's like
that's a full that's a full journey like
we started together and
not a lot of people unless you were
seriously in the comics really even knew
who the guardians were
and everybody was you know speculating
you know professional wrestlers playing
drags and you know is this going to be
the first
you know marvel film to flop and it was
a lot of that until it came out
people just fell in love with it and it
was almost like uh
um and and this is not my word so i
don't want to get
beaten up by this but someone i've heard
a lot of people say this is like the new
star wars and people are going to look
back on guardians
the way we look back our generation
looks back on star wars and that like
saying something like that like that's a
bold statement and that like
hits me and i you know it's yet to be
seen but if if we could even
if i you know could have somebody
feeling that way about guardians the way
i feel and look back on star wars i mean
that's
man that's a life worth live man that's
something special i mean that's
leaving uh that's a legacy man so anyway
i'm really excited to wrap up this whole
journey with these guys i love them i
love the guardians cast like family
they know it i think i think everybody
knows it i'm pretty pretty vocal about
it
well i was i was going to ask i mean not
not to delve too much into the more
negative side of it but there was a bit
there where
we didn't know what was going on with
guardians 3. with the whole
the whole thing with james and you know
at collider we were very
very vocally not not okay with it but
i'm wondering
sort of what it was like behind the
scenes at that moment and
what it's like to have that you know in
the past now
it was at the time it was awful and
thank you for being vocal and that was
that was the one thing that you know
really made it
it just made it okay and it just helped
me a lot because i got man i got beat up
and i got bash and i got threatened
and i got you know i was in a bad spot
with disney as well but i just you know
i just felt like i was
doing the right thing and i felt like
you know a friend a guy who really
went out on a limb for me and kind of
changed my life was
being unfairly attacked and he was
unfairly attacked
and then he was unfairly punished and so
i i just couldn't live with myself if i
didn't say anything but it was
at the time it was awful like it was
awful and i literally stayed
like on social media at that time even
though i was just getting bashed and
beaten up i stayed
on it because i knew if you know nobody
was speaking up for him then he was just
there was just no chance
and this was like a wrong this was like
a part of you know the climate the
political climate the you know things
that were going on it was like even much
bigger than james this was like this was
like a big message that they were
sending
uh this was a personal political attack
on james gunn
and you know i you know disney i just
don't i think they
they jumped the gun they made a rash
decision uh they made a mistake
and i think you know eventually they
they really did the right thing and
which
was another huge statement for disney to
go back and say
hey guys we made a mistake we're gonna
hire we're hiring james back i mean that
in itself is a huge statement
and so yeah i don't want to overlook
that at all that was something that like
they
really even put themselves out on a limb
which they didn't need to do because
they could have moved on
and just gone on without and they still
the next guardians would made a load of
money and people would come out to see
it because they're so invested in it
but they didn't they did they did the
right thing they said hey guys we made a
mistake
and that in itself is a message but
there was no there was no way in hell
that i was just gonna leave james
hanging out there to fight for himself
and defend himself
for something that he wasn't guilty of
it was just a designed attack by
horrible people you know horrible people
and there's just no way i was just gonna
you know sit there and do nothing about
it saying nothing about it and you guys
too
like it really helped a lot and it made
me feel good to see
that so many like big outlets were
coming out and saying this isn't this
not right this is not okay
and we can't let these guys get away
with it because if this if they get away
with this
this is going to continue to happen and
it's going to get worse and this you
know it's
going to be a snowball going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger uh so a lot
of people
you know they really stepped up up to
the plate and stood up for james which
needed to happen because he needed help
and uh so yeah thankfully they they
hired him back and
because he was already on suicide squad
things got really arranged
guardians got pushed but it's done deal
man we're making we're making that film
man we're going into it um later this
year and it's
sign shield and delivered to do it i'm
excited about it and uh and yeah that's
it man we'll wrap up this story
and i asked about the dune script but
what's your sort of first reaction to
james's guardians 3 script i haven't
read it
i haven't read it yeah so yeah
yeah i haven't read it and and i will
and we'll sit down eventually we'll go
james is big on rehearsals
big on table reads so that'll probably
be the first time that i'll actually
read as we go and sit down and do the
table read
yeah which will be in november of this
year yeah
so to jump right from you know to james
to zack snyder who is
you know i i just watched the film last
night and it's it's one of it's one of
the bigger films i've seen
in a long time and i'm curious because i
this is the first
of zack's films where he was his own
cinematographer
yeah and i'm wondering what your
experience was like uh working
was it was if there's any difference
between working with him as a director
and when he was in sort of
cinematographer mode
um you know it's weird because i
couldn't distinguish between the two
because it was never
there was never any separation there was
never that moment where zach didn't have
a camera in his hands he just wasn't
that moment like he was always the guy
he was always a guy on camera number one
he was carrying you know a camera he was
there carrying it was in your face
and you got notes in between takes but
he was always
he was just always there he was always
you know right there in the pit with us
he uh
so it's hard to you know you know
usually
like when i'm working on a film i hardly
ever
or you know in a workwise way you know
talk to the dp you know i may get notes
here and there but they usually always
come
through the director or the first ad but
usually i'm always getting notes from
the director
so it was uh you know it was kind of a
really great
special experience just you know have
zach there with a camera his shoulder
directing you but it was also really
something interesting because
there are a few times when he was he
wanted particular things
um he wanted to capture just like simple
little things and performances
and we talked about it and he said i
want to do this again i want to cover it
from here here
and there he is he's are still got the
camera and he's covering a certain way
and these were mostly like very nuanced
things so he was like very
up close and personal with that camera
but it was like a
i don't know a real kind of bonding
experience like i just felt like
we were in this together and we're
connected like we're working together
uh so no i mean it was a really special
experience i've never
experienced anything like it before or
since and i don't know if i ever will
again
it was really something special to see a
director just
you know dragging around the camera and
just like going for broke and not only
because most of the time zach had a
handheld
so it's not like a camera was setting up
and he didn't see anything he said he
was like discovering stuff
as we were going as we were moving and
that you know when you're doing stuff
like that that's when it
like it makes me feel like an artist and
like i want to feel like an artist i
feel like it's a performance art and i
love
i love thinking about it like that so i
like that he's discovering stuff as
we're going and as we're moving as we're
working as we're filming
and things are changing so it's not just
something that's so stiff it's something
on paper or something that we
we're going to shoot from this way we're
going to shoot from that way it's like
if he sees like this tiny little angle
that he thinks may be interesting he's
got a camera and he's just up in there
and uh and you know i love that and i
respect and i learned from it you know
which is the most important thing i
really wanted to learn to learn from
zach
i wish we could have talked a little bit
that flew by
yeah but it was a pleasure talking to
you man thank you
from the ring to the movies i think it's
it's been it's been
wild to watch your korean it's been one
it's been wonderful